this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone you
choose chef's designed recipes and blue
apron delivers fresh seasonally inspired
ingredients cook incredible meals unless
in as little as 20 minutes check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blue apron dot-com
slash Congrats
that's blue apron dot-com / congrats to
get your first three meals free the cash
app you already know the cash app is the
number one finance app on the app store
what you might not know is that you can
also put cash app in your wallet with
the cash card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one we'll talk about this more later on
in the show
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or a Google Play market hey
how you guys doing it's Chris D'Elia
here and we're doing it we're doing it
for episode 90 and you may have heard
something a little bit different so far
when I read the ads and that's to let
you [ __ ] know what's up man
their ads you don't get you get to
listen to this for free they come up on
your on your podcast app on your app
whatever you got you get listened to for
free and I want to just remind people
that when they're when they complain
about ads which has been happening less
and less that that's why you get to
listen to it for free because I get to
get paid through these ads so every time
I read a [ __ ] ad just so you know
dude okay that's how it's going so
here's a little bit reminder if you're
feeling a little bit complaining guess
what that's how it's gonna be from now
on do it that's how it's gonna be from
now on I'm coming in [ __ ] feisty
today dude that's what's up dude did
some shows this past weekend
in I did a college in New Jersey called
[ __ ] college in New Jersey and
Trenton did a [ __ ] did the Warner
Theatre in DC and I also did the [ __ ]
Carnegie Hall and I played the hometown
in Montclair New Jersey so that's what's
up dude that's how we're [ __ ] doing
it from now on man cuz that's how it is
in this life man you got a [ __ ] you
got to get it in where you got to get it
where you you got to get in where you
fit in that's what you do so that's
what's up we got some new sponsors and
[ __ ] like that we'd love the new
sponsors we'd love to tried-and-true old
sponsors we got [ __ ] we got remember
if you're watching the video app kudus
reminding you you got CUDA right here
over my right shoulder to remind you and
then you got the [ __ ] Eagle over here
to remind you who the [ __ ] you're
listening to dude anyway dude I was on
the road Wow where do we [ __ ] start
here I was on the road do you know what
actually first I want to talk about I
was on the road and I saw we've probably
talked about infomercials here and there
by the way this isn't plugged in is this
usually plugged in it is it's not
plugged in it's not plugged in it's out
of here but is that it I'll do it so so
one fire starting off already
and that's not it okay well whatever its
if it dies it dies if he dies he dies
it's got some up there we need to fix it
we get so nervous is we need to fix that
we're having a [ __ ] technical
difficulty you cuz you're [ __ ] wanna
fire so we so so I was in LA or no I'm
sorry I was in what the [ __ ] was I when
I was listening to this watching this
[ __ ] I was in I first of all I can't
even can't tell you a house a [ __ ]
[ __ ] one fires looking trying to get
her on the studio behind the camera to
try and [ __ ] plug in the the sound
thing
because he looks extremely submit but uh
I can't find what you know what it is
well we got to find it right are those
gonna go he's gonna start over okay so I
was in where was that when I was doing
that
oh I stayed in Philly
and when I stayed in Philly I was like
there was this infomercial that came on
called Peabo Bryson 'he's classic R&B or
classic soul hits or whatever
now people Bryson was an old singer that
looks a little bit he was like the free
he looks like I don't know how old he is
now but he did he was like a soul singer
and like a Nate but like Nate Dogg but
like he look a little bit like Nick doll
like he was bald and [ __ ] but it would
the infomercial that I saw do you guys
watch infomercials cuz I watch him for
merciless man and I love watching
infomercials because they make me feel
because I don't really have to pay
attention but also they're selling some
[ __ ] and I know they don't believe in it
now that's the best they don't believe
in that this one is a little different
maybe people Bryson did like a lot of
the things that this guy was saying
maybe people present did like a lot of
things that did these guys made him sell
but he he was selling first of all
compact discs and its 2018 now it looked
originally when this infomercial was
created and it was created in 2005 so
this thing's 13 years old
and they still did the thing where they
were like if you call in the next 18
minutes you'll get this free like no man
so you know that those are [ __ ] you
know those are [ __ ] now you never
need to call the next one they're like
if you call in the next 10 minutes
you'll get you know those are [ __ ]
because this was made in 2005 and they
were still doing it 13 years later so 13
years later you can be if you call in
the next 13 years you can still get what
the [ __ ] it is you want to get
it was 13 years later now I watched this
[ __ ] now first of all you don't know
here's the thing one fire go the other
way you know anyway um I got to do a
little bit of a technical difficulty
here I got to plug this in here so you
guys [ __ ] hold on one second while
we're got while you were holding on you
know what
we're in it we're in it we're in it host
hit his head so hard on the [ __ ]
thing god I wish you could see how it's
a [ __ ] you want fire lux trying to get
around the studio alright so so people
Preston is doing this [ __ ] and they're
all the songs like by Lionel Richie and
Marvin Gaye and [ __ ] like that and
they're talking about how great it is
but when you watch you ever watch like a
football play that happened last week it
always looks like it's from the 80s did
you ever notice that if they're like do
a show a little bit of a clip from a
last week's game it always you're always
like why the [ __ ] does this look like it
was so it looks like a copy of a copy of
a copy that's so grainy like but but
this [ __ ] 2005 it's crazy how different
broadcasting was in 2005 so first of all
they're selling compact compact discs
and they're doing it still in 2018 hey
guys get with it okay also people bryson
change your name of course
peebo uh you know peebo Bryson so so it
really but the thing about it no I had a
really emotional weekend and this is
what started it off I was watching this
infomercial and it was just so insane to
see this [ __ ] an infomercial I saw 13
years ago to see how different the world
is now like you can't buy a compact
discs even I don't know who the [ __ ]
might like literally they're trying to
sell the last few that they have to the
people dying tomorrow you know like a 90
year old is just like I want to get this
I want to get this cuz I like all those
soul songs and I've been looking for
that Marvin Gaye song you know and so I
was sitting there watching these info
this infomercial and it was really
affecting me in a real way I started
thinking about how it used to be when I
was a kid now by the way in 2005 I was
25 I was barely a kid but it was just
the whole nostalgia of it made me feel
like I was young again and I was like
wow man it's crazy how much has changed
since I
[ __ ] we since in in in [ __ ] 13
years so now I go I do that I do a gig
in New Jersey which I'm from New Jersey
okay
and I played Trenton New Jersey which is
the College of New Jersey which hey
College I appreciate a name like that
the College of New Jersey if did if I
had a college for that your god that
when people are like nah it's cool to
have [ __ ] like I don't know many
colleges because I'm an idiot but like
some of them are called like like Duke
like what the [ __ ] you know pick
wherever you are that's what it's like
when I say about the band's like you're
supposed to be named the Beatles or the
birds or the [ __ ] Lions you know don't
get all [ __ ] Death Cab for Cutie
[ __ ] on me with your college [ __ ] oh
yeah where do you go to college
[ __ ] what's that one Mellon Carnegie
Mellon well is that a city
it's two guys last names go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] yourself dude what are
you a law firm [ __ ] Carnegie Mellon
law Carnegie Mellon out law the Law
Offices of Carnegie Mellon Carnegie and
Mellon how about when they do [ __ ]
when they're brothers and they do like
Carnegie and Carnegie they're like when
they did when they're the most Jewish
last names of all time and it's the Law
Offices of Rosenbaum and Rosenbaum I'll
go [ __ ] yourself just say the Rosenbaum
law offices man so I got a repeat I got
a repeat it twice
you [ __ ] egotistical set widow to
choose so so anyway what's up with all
the Jews they always named in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] with it you gotta say it twice ha
ha ha ha I mean so many [ __ ]
callbacks to other episodes people
listening to the new [ __ ] definitely
people listening to the new episode
definitely turning it off right now
so I was so yeah but call your college
College of New Jersey to define a
college whatever state it would be it
will be the college of that goddamn
state that's the [ __ ] California College
of [ __ ] Oregon
you know Oregon State however they do it
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] don't get
creative with it with the thing No mmm
it's a college everyone wants to know
where it is so I put the college in New
Jersey and then I went and I played DC
which was fine whatever then I went to
play Carnegie Hall in New York and it
was insane here's the deal man
Carnegie Hall is the most traditional
traditional most legendary probably
venue or at least theater in the in
America and it was in New York they
started it in 1891 and I was like trying
to get ironed out all the details before
I got there like oh yeah I want to get I
want to sell merchandise I want to want
to do it before the show usually my
opener Mike he gets out there and he
sells merchandise he sells our
merchandise before the show and he loves
doing it and he goes ourselves before
the show and then he sells it after the
show
Carnegie Hall was like can't sell it
before the show and I was like why that
makes no sense and I was like because
there's an intermission I was like what
there's not intermission in my [ __ ]
comedy show and they're like no we got
to do it because they make a lot of
money a lot of these theaters they make
a lot of money in intermission because
the [ __ ] bar sales in the
intermission and I was like well I don't
want to do it they were like well then
there's a fee and I was like go [ __ ]
yourself dude there's a feed they wanted
to charge me for not having an
intermission at so I was like no tell
him no and then my managers came up to
me as I saw I tried and I'm like it's
fine about like we're gonna have to pay
so we're gonna have to I was like
alright that's fine then I'm just gonna
walk out afterwards
it's fine we could so I said can we sell
merch in the intermission he said yeah
so I said ok good so then then we're all
good they wouldn't let Mike sell the
merch so they had the [ __ ] guys at
Carnegie Hall sell the merch
so now by the way I hate was emergency
merchandise but I'm I'm a coda I guess
so
they [ __ ] sell on the merch and we
didn't make as much money as we usually
do which is fine but then afterwards we
sold the merch anyway whatever it
doesn't matter about the merchant what
matters is I was getting pissed off
before the show I was like I know but
about I hired a photographer and they
were like you can't take pictures here
here here here here here here I was like
what the [ __ ] can you take pictures like
in the back or outside ah quite a higher
so anyway I'm paying this guy a bunch of
money to shoot the [ __ ] night right
by the way everybody okay so I'm pissed
off at the at the venue right and
they're like oh by the way he needs to
come and do a mandatory soundcheck and
I'm like what I'm a [ __ ] comedian not
the killers
I'm not Death Cab for Cutie I'm not
[ __ ] Sparkle horse dude did put out a
monitor and a microphone we're fine
they're like now we want him to walk
around this theatre and get a feel for
it
hey man every shows are the same I live
in the [ __ ] what's that Bill Murray
movie over and over again Groundhog Day
I live in every day's the [ __ ] same I
go I do my [ __ ] it's fine if I need to
adjust I do it in [ __ ] one bill a
second cuz it's from a job so they
they're like he by the way he has to
show two and a half hours early at the
soundcheck which is the worst shitty
amount of time because I gotta go before
I don't have enough time to go back to
chill and then come back so I just gotta
hang there for two and a half hours but
up pop by yeah go [ __ ] yourself
no but then in the back of my head I'm
like well I'm still got to make this
[ __ ] money
so let's relax so I'm trying to get to
the [ __ ] soundcheck I don't go two
and a half hours early I go an hour and
a half early which is fine we we settled
on what negotiation [ __ ] you don't even
need to negotiate
so I'm there and I walk in the theatre I
walk into the actual theater and it like
hits me that I'm playing Carnegie Hall
which by the way I didn't even think
about I told my dad that I was gonna
play Carnegie Hall and he started crying
because he's from New York
his dad my grandpa used to sell
newspapers on the corner outside in
[ __ ] New York City and my dad said
Wow I've only seen George Carlin there
at the [ __ ] eye Carnegie Hall and I
can't even believe you're gonna I'm
gonna dat's the next time I'm gonna see
you Carnegie Hall is you Wow and so for
Father's Day I got him a vintage George
Carlin shirt and he looks at me and he
starts crying and he says I'm gonna wear
this I'm gonna wear this when you play
Carnegie Hall and I said oh cool is it
because you know why and I do know why
because he's a buddy he'll told me again
my dad's a master of saying [ __ ] 75
times he was like because I saw George
Carlin play Carnegie Hall and that's the
only I know that's the only other time
no no but that's the only other time
I've been to Carnegie Hall and it was in
the step no no it was in the seventy but
it was in the 70s okay no I know that
how do you know that because you tell me
that four hundred seventy five times he
says well and he's crying okay my dad is
so sentimental he cries at the end of
[ __ ] every TV show he watches right
I'd be like that what's going on is I
just Lauren order so so so I get to
Carnegie Hall and when I step on the
stage on the stage to do the soundcheck
or whatever which by the way this is the
soundcheck
oh cool one two great works out right so
I get out there I step out onto the
stage dude
it's actually breathtaking this stage if
you've never been to Carnegie Hall it's
so [ __ ] annoying how goddamn
beautiful it is it's annoying that you
can't go in there with a bat I was like
you know what I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
talk to the guy in charge I'm gonna give
him a piece on my mind I'd be like you
care saw merchandising the beginning
that's so ridiculous I get out there and
I'm like
it's gold the theater is golden white
it's beautiful and you don't realize how
many times you've seen it like on in
movies and on TV and [ __ ] like that I
don't know how by the way because I
don't know how the [ __ ] they filmed
because they're not allowed to [ __ ]
shoot anywhere but I step out there and
I'm like wow and I think about my
parents and everybody that's gonna be
out there a my my my my family and my
friends and people that I've met the
years and [ __ ] that are gonna be out
there supporting me and it [ __ ] made
me feel like emotional okay again all
the way from [ __ ] Peabo Bryson [ __ ]
feeling nostalgic now I'm over at
Carnegie Hall now my dad tonight
at this night is gonna make me feel
nostalgic nostalgic for him to solve it
for me and it's logic for him that's
aweso for everyone so I am
listen I'm like okay so here comes to
show everyone now gets to the show I do
the show fine I got everybody there I
got my my dad my [ __ ] uncle my
everybody second cousins [ __ ] friends
my girl
[ __ ] Miller is not there my brother
and and because he had [ __ ] a
deadline and [ __ ] like that and I told
him not to come because don't stress the
[ __ ] out oh I was like it's okay if you
don't come because it wouldn't make all
[ __ ] and Dan doesn't matter it's [ __ ]
sold out anyway so so I'm [ __ ] do the
show and I get a standing ovation at the
end I'm not trying to [ __ ] brag
whatever but it I was sitting there
taking it all in and I almost [ __ ] it
was very emotional
got some cool shots the photographer was
able to finagle some cool shots I get
out and I'm like I'm gonna be anyway my
point is is that I was in New York where
I [ __ ] my dad you know my dad loved
to see me perform I'm a mom as well and
[ __ ] and every time I saw my dad
afterwards he was like it was like an
out-of-body experience and [ __ ] like
that and just trying to [ __ ] he was
trying to he cried the whole time
you know little [ __ ] has [ __ ] you know
my dad and I got a little bit of that
sentimentality from him my brother did
not but so then we all went to eat about
forty five of us and I just sat there
and I was like damn it's crazy how we're
all together because you don't get to
see people all the time you know like
the only time you get to see people as a
family is weddings and when people die
right so everyone's toast to my uncle
Vinny's there
he brought Underberg by the way if you
if you are there if you're a
congratulations pond
he brought a bunch of different under
Berg's for everybody that have alcohol
in him by the way my cousin was trying
his luck here you got to drink some I
was like there's alcohol in this and
then they were like yet it's [ __ ]
alcohol in it so I'm like I'm not gonna
drink the [ __ ] and we're do or having a
good time and then and then my girl
almost [ __ ] chokes you ever seen
someone choked by the way you ever see
the terror in their face I actually
don't know if I want to [ __ ] even get
too far into this because it was really
[ __ ] up because I had such an
emotional night and then seeing somebody
that you care about almost died from
choke by the way choking is that we're
gonna be the worst is that's got to be
the worst way to go it's got to be the
worst way to go because you choked
first of all choking is the weirdest
thing cuz you have to do it to live
you've got to eat to live but it can
also kill you
that's not fair Jesus Christ hey Jesus
Christ that's not fair what the [ __ ] son
of God what are you doing we've got to
eat and that can kill us hey Jesus
Christ what are you doing I'd rather see
someone I love commit suicide or jump in
or jump or get hit by a train then
[ __ ] almost choke you see there look
on their face 12 seconds of pure hell it
all worked out she coughed it up I did
the Heimlich
but I like to take credit for it and I
was trying to do it my aunt was like
lower flower looked like I was just
trying to cop a feel
David Copperfield how about the least
funniest [ __ ] president ever David
Copperfield
squeeze how [ __ ] hilarious all right
I mean I guess it's not hilarious but
how amazing would it be how braised the
wave you just went
David Copperfield magician is and she
said who and he goes David cop of
coppaFeel
and he goes squeeze and then he just
says you're a survivor
[Laughter]
good hey sweetheart
yeah first of all that sexist but hey
sweetheart yeah you know who my favorite
magician is who David Copperfield
squeeze you're a survivor and then
wheels off in his wheelchair Wow would
be my [ __ ] most favorite present
gonna hell going to hell but still it's
all good babies you can't take it with
you but it's all good in the meantime I
mean so slow you know the [ __ ]
backing up the Brinks truck in the
meantime so slow yeah man anyway it was
a nostalgic weekend and then the next
night I go pessoa so between the [ __ ]
almost joking the show and the people
Bryson [ __ ] which started it off I'm
telling you that started off my
nostalgic weekend my The Crying all my
family members and [ __ ] be in there
Carnegie Hall I was I was just on an
emotional roller coaster right so then I
go to play Montclair New Jersey which is
where I'm from and I'm playing Montclair
New Jersey and my best friend from
Montclair New Jersey who I used to live
next door from people don't get to do
this dude he hits me up and he's like
hey do you want to get in to you
or old house that you grew up in and in
my head I go like this
no because it's gonna be too emotional
for me but I had already but joke's on
you that's that conversation happened a
week before I'm telling you and I said
yes already so it's like pulp fiction
now I'm telling the story you don't know
what the beginning is and what the end
is so so now I go see the [ __ ] old
house I grew up in dude and I don't want
to give you the address cuz you guys are
crazy
and you'll show up but I go and I
stepped it now it's been 25 no it's been
26 seven years since I've been in that
house
26 years and I step in and my [ __ ]
I'm overwhelmed with emotion already
from the from everything in the weekend
and I'm in the house I grew up in and I
and all these [ __ ] emotions are
flooding back to me I'm like oh my god
this is where I asked my mom if I could
say the word [ __ ] for the first time and
she said ok and I got scared and I ran
away I said then at the in the dining
room I was like hey mom can I say the S
word it's a swear word and she said yeah
and I said what really and she said sure
you could do it once and I said now I'm
too scared and I ran away like a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ok and then I was like oh this is the
[ __ ] these are the stairs I ran down
during for when when we that one
Christmas and I and I ran past my
brother cuz they told they told my
brother to let my brother go first cause
he was littler and I thought that was
[ __ ] so I blasted right by him and
his head hit the [ __ ] side of the
wall and he and he didn't miss the smile
and we have video of it dude
one time I was running now for Christmas
and my brother my brother was running
down for Chris was walking every
Christmas he's going too slow cuz he had
little legs and I was a little bit older
and and and they were like let Matt go
first let Matt go first and I blew right
by him and I hit him into the wall and
he was smiling because it was Christmas
and his head hit the [ __ ] side of the
wall and he didn't stop smiling and kept
walking and dude we laugh cuz it was so
funny cuz he was just he knew he hurt
himself but he was still too excited cuz
santa came real [ __ ] dude that is real
[ __ ] man
so and I was like oh this was the
[ __ ] part where I realized I had OCD
this was the moment where I realized I
had OCD because I was lining up my micro
machines in a row and uncle Vinny with
the [ __ ]
two wallets came over and sat down
before Underberg and he was like hey
what's this when I really liked it and I
screamed at the top of my lungs because
he missed he messed up my cars he messed
up my Micro Machines man they were
supposed to be on the line he picked one
up and he wasn't supposed to do that and
in my little head with OCD that was his
fault he picked up a car zone he wasn't
supposed to and he put it back because I
screamed like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
whatever dude it's what makes me me no
she did doctors will tell you that's not
what makes you who you are because OCD
is a demon and it's not a part of you
but I would argue it helps with the
creativity now is that a [ __ ] bad
thing to say to people who have OCD yeah
cuz maybe it will make your feet into
your own OCD yeah but don't do that I
guess but also if it could it could be
gene okay if you're [ __ ] if you have
OCD and you were really into math and
that helps you do math it could be Jane
or it could be [ __ ] serial killer and
keep [ __ ] heads in your freezer so
anyway I was like oh this is the part
this is where and they opened up walls
and they built here's the other thing
too when you go back to a place that you
haven't been to in 25 years it's so much
and now it's so much it shrinks I don't
give a [ __ ] what people say purely like
oh but you were littler and your memory
distorted it nope things get smaller I
walked into that house it was so much
[ __ ] smaller than I remember it and
guess what that's not my fault
it [ __ ] shrunk my house shrunk dude
um I was walking downstairs and I was
like oh this is the moment but this is
the moment where ice are I where I
remember starting the moment I know the
moment I believed I started believing in
God and I'm not saying I believe in it
anymore I don't know who knows if
there's a [ __ ] God or an afterlife I
don't [ __ ] know and if you say there
is one if you say there isn't one you
[ __ ] idiot because guess what you
don't know you know why you're live and
anyone who's alive hasn't died yet you
saw a bright light you almost died cool
that's your mind [ __ ] with you
doesn't mean [ __ ]
doesn't mean [ __ ] [ __ ] diddle in
then-then-then so um so now I am I
remember the moment I believing in God
when I was a kid one other kid I
believed in God dude how [ __ ] kid is
it to believe in God you know how I
started believing in God when I was a
kid I was uh I was looking for some I
don't even remember what it was but was
it was a toy and let me tell you
something it was very [ __ ] important
okay
I needed the toy and I couldn't find it
I looked all over the house and I was
standing at the top of the stairs in the
basement cuz I was on the East Coast and
East Coast have basements and West Coast
don't have basements for some [ __ ]
reason but that's how it is in America
so I said God in my head as a [ __ ]
crazy little ass [ __ ] OCD ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was like God if you
just tell me where this [ __ ] toy is I
will believe in you and right then I
thought oh gods telling me God's telling
me it's in the basement under the end
table with the lamp on it and I ran
downstairs and I looked under the end
table with the lamp on it and there was
the toy and I sat on the floor and I
thought oh my god there is a god I
didn't realize that my mind is my mind
and I can come up with those ideas by
myself in my head God put it now here's
the here's the thing people still think
of [ __ ] like that and they're adults and
they're not they don't live in [ __ ]
like tribes and [ __ ] they have like
walls and toasters and an actual
functioning society and people still
think God give them ideas like that now
those people you're crazy okay you're a
crazy lunatic why because that's your
mind but I was [ __ ] eight and that's
when I was like there's a god so I just
want you to know if you're an adult that
thinks that you're eight
secretly eight um but that's what I
started believing in God yep and then
there was I was I looked at the [ __ ]
back window and I remember the back
window I remember that's where I got my
first [ __ ] boner dude I remember
that's where I got my first boner man
where I started to like chicks because I
was what I was I was I was looking at
the the glass windowpane I remember
playing with toys in the glass windows
paint with my [ __ ] neighbor Julie and
she was a little bit older and we were
playing with toys in the glass window
pane and it looked the grouts the window
pane shrunk dude it shrunk I didn't get
bigger it shrunk dude and my memory is
shrunk and so and so we're playing with
toys and I saw the [ __ ] and I was
like damn dude I kind of wanted to like
touch Julie that's how I got my first
boner I was probably toys and a wit near
the window dude they redid the kitchen
they put another balcony and over into
the balcony I was like oh dude they
don't have this balcony anymore they
made it in they covered it and I was
part of the inside and I was like this
is where I broke the indestructible
plate so I was like my mom told me that
the plates were indestructible and that
you could drop him and there Britain
they don't break and so I was trying to
[ __ ] impress my friend Keith testa
and I was like these don't [ __ ] break
look and I came out went outside and I
took the plate and I was like I dropped
it on the stone and it shattered into a
million pieces and I looked at Keith and
I was like oh it's supposed to not break
and I was like my brother unbreakable
plates I just like you can't throw him
on the [ __ ] ground outside don't call
him [ __ ] unbreakable place that's how
I started developing personality all
sorts of [ __ ] I got to do ads [ __ ] but
then I remembered also there's a park
behind the [ __ ] plate I mean I
remember everything man we used to in
the park we used to [ __ ] bury dirty
pictures me and my [ __ ] best friend
Matt we used to bury pictures of girls
with [ __ ] from Playboy that [ __ ]
Thomas used to take used to give us cuz
he was the older kid that had [ __ ]
bad parents he had to [ __ ] play boys
and he would rip out the pages and he
would give us us he would give us
pictures of nude chicks
or [ __ ] those potato skin treats that
we you would have I would go and he'll
be like y'all give you a picture of this
chick if you [ __ ] give me your potato
skin bytes and I'd be like yo say no
more fam here are my potato skin bytes
let me see that [ __ ] chicks teddies
and he would give me them and I put him
in my pocket and I feel like [ __ ]
thumb thumb thumb thumb thumb in second
grade all around the [ __ ] school in
the playground through [ __ ] recess
through language arts I will be [ __ ]
keepin titties in my pocket dude and
I've got teens in my pocket and the
other one is touching my boner later man
so then I went and I buried the [ __ ]
pictures of titties in a base in a
baseball [ __ ] card box and I buried
him in the back of [ __ ] Jannik or
Brook Park and the [ __ ] kid who lived
on the other side of Hannibal Carr Brook
Park this mother [ __ ] [ __ ] ass told
my dad about it he came back and was
like mrs. Li I want you to know now this
is where I learned some [ __ ] dude my my
dad he told my dad he was like I want
you to know Chris and Matt are doing
some bad [ __ ] and my dad said oh yeah
what and he knocked on this [ __ ] door
and he said oh yeah what he said they
got dirty pictures of girls in the back
Chanukah Brook Park and my dad said oh
yeah he said yeah he said okay and he
close the [ __ ] door on him and my dad
told me about that [ __ ] and I said did
you get mad and he said of course I
didn't get mad and even if I was mad I
wasn't gonna let that [ __ ] kid know
that I was mad because he thought he was
telling on you and I wanted him to feel
stupid dude are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's some [ __ ] woke up this mornin
and got yourself a gun that's so [ __ ]
dope and Mafia [ __ ] my dad did that when
I forget his name I think it was Mike
something all [ __ ] shitty guys her
name Mike you know and he was but any
[ __ ] told he was like yo I want you to
know my dad oh really I said okay ain't
close the [ __ ] door
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that's what my dad did to
[ __ ] that shitty kid and then of
course my [ __ ] friend Matt got in
trouble too but not really though
because because we weren't gonna let
that kid have his cake and eat it too
[ __ ] that kid [ __ ] him as a seven year
old hungry [ __ ] and then you know what I
did as a [ __ ] boss player you know
what I did as a [ __ ] boss player dude
how's the [ __ ] boss player when I was
nine I [ __ ] went the next day I took
potato skins and I traded them for
Thomas for some more [ __ ] nudie
pictures and then oh you're probably
like oh you you know you probably
shouldn't have done that cuz he already
got caught well guess what I [ __ ] did
I came home I took those nudie pictures
and I walked up to my dad's office my
dad was in his office I walked up I
knocked on the door open the door
I [ __ ] threw the nudie pictures on
his desk and I said those are the pics
and I walked out [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yup dude that's how we're living as
daliyah's dude hey Mike you think you're
gonna [ __ ] unearth some dirty titties
you think you're gonna unearth some
dirty tickets tip 30 titties in a public
park and get me in trouble by telling my
dad about that [ __ ] Oh guess what
[ __ ] I still got some potato
skins to spare [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
that's right man
I loved going back to my [ __ ] old
house dude all right dude
we've got to add brakes all right all
right you guys post mates as usual your
stomach and the rest of your life are at
war you need to eat but you can't stop
what you're doing to deal with it and
the only things the only fast things
that deliver are not what you want you
know I'm talking about that's so
annoying introducing post mates the app
that adds a delivery option to your
favorite restaurants imagine anything
you want to eat delivered you don't have
to drive park or even talk on the phone
to order just download the app and order
24 hours a day 365 days a year post
mates will bring you what you want
within the hour you could even see where
your food is and track your driver you
forgot to get eggs and milk no problem
craving a tasty burger check looking for
the perfect bottle of red wine or a
summer beer order up post mates is your
new long-term munchies booty call I
didn't write that part for a limited
time post mates is giving you $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app today and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with codes with code
congrats zebra lost my mind it's it has
been reported that Americans are
overpaying on car insurance by over 21
billion dollars dude do you know how
much that is because guess what I don't
it's too much but searching for a better
deal can take hours and typically
results in a barrage of unwanted spam
calls until now thanks to the zebra comm
the zebra comm is the nation's leading
car insurance comparison site because
it's the only place you can compare
hundreds of policies from all the top
carriers and choose the best for you
Plus
we'll never sell your information to the
spammers that's important so you won't
be annoyed you won't get all those
unwanted calls or emails the zebra works
you just answer a few questions on a
simple fast form and they find you the
best rates and coverage in your state
TechCrunch said it best the zebra is
kayak for auto insurance it's quick and
easy just an honest way to compare car
insurance quotes from all the top
providers all at once all right
it's just one of those things that
should have existed before and it's a
great service it didn't exist till now
it's how buying car insurance should be
go today and start saving this at the
zebra dot-com / congrats that's the
zebra dot-com / congrats spelled ZEB are
a.com slash Congrats blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes to your door I love blue still
another week gone by still haven't had a
bad blue apron and I eat them at least
once or twice a week you choose chef's
design recipes deliver fresh seasonally
inspired ingredients cook incredible
meals in as little as twenty minutes and
you don't have to be a chef to do it
it's very easy they break it down for
you quick and easy recipes up recipe
options with insanely delicious flavors
I'm telling you Chris D'Elia
skip meal planning and shopping and get
straight to cooking with blue apron it
offers a range of recipes bursting with
flavor whether you're looking for quick
and easy meals or a full culinary
cooking experience blue apron they got
it tomato and basil pesto pizza
stir-fried sweet chili chicken seared
beef dumplings and jasmine rice to
dumplings are so good and the best
dumplings come from blue imprint so
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free at blue apron
dot-com / Congrats
that's blue apron dot-com / Congrats to
get your first 3 meals fully free blue
apron a better way to cook
you already know the cash up is the
number one finance app on the App Store
what you might not know is you can also
put cash up in your wallet with the cash
card it's the only debit card that
offers instant rewards and comes packed
with premium features not even a credit
card can offer like boosts save up to
10% instantly at Whole Foods Wendy's or
Chipotle and more of your favorite spots
or even $1 off coffee every time you
swipe your card your cash card at coffee
shops across the country which you know
I like to do it because I got I like I
like caffeine unlike coffee the cash
card puts you in control of your money
with an with extra in-app safety
features that let you pause your card
with a touch unlike a credit card there
are no fees ever and a credit check
isn't required to get one so download
the cash app now and get your cash card
for free visit the App Store or Google
Play market now and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund it's a true win-win you guys I'm
coming on Miami
bienvenido a Miami I'm going to Miami
you can get ticket to Chris D'Elia calm
follow-the-leader tour a lot of stuff
sold out but Miami's coming up I'm
looking forward to going to Portland
it's all sold out man I'm looking
forward to go to Portland and [ __ ]
Seattle and also I'm gonna Vancouver
doing two shows in Vancouver
by the way so anyway yeah
what else did I see when I went away on
the way home uh when I saw him [ __ ]
way home what else did I see dad I just
it was crazy going back I saw that my
brother peed down the laundry chute
that's another one
my brother [ __ ] had a fever and he
and he was walking around and he peed
dozen laundry chute did I used to have
[ __ ] crazy dreams about my mom's
laundry room too
I used to have recurring dreams about
how there were seances at my mom's
laundry room and how I used to try and
fit myself down the laundry chute
hey that's gotta mean something [ __ ]
up right
seances um yeah man
I used to get you know what else
happened also I used to be out of my
mind scared when I was uh when I was a
kid I used to run into my moms and dads
pack the room into my parents room and
that would be like hey guys I'm scared
I'd be like okay well you gotta go to
bed and be like no I know but I'm just
scared and then one time did I talk
about this in the pakka's my dad said
what are you scared of and I said Birds
everything that I said that yeah I did I
would be scared of everything I will be
so scared and you know what's weird is -
I got you ever wake up in the middle
night and and you're scared I I mean
that hasn't happened and since I was
like 15 maybe but what was weird is it
happened on Thursday know when I was in
Philadelphia I woke up in the middle of
the night and I looked into the other
room my hotel room had didn't just have
the whole term it also had another room
because it was in a [ __ ] it was a
suite and I looked and I was like what
if like a [ __ ] shadowy figure or a
demon or a ghost was just there and then
I couldn't [ __ ] fall asleep again cuz
I was like what if there is a shadowy
figure in a [ __ ] demon or a beast
there and I had to get up and close the
door like a [ __ ] bitch-ass so I could
sleep again and I think I turned the
[ __ ] TV on and the light on I'm 38
dude
what a [ __ ] but I was scared and then
God it was so weird dude I never felt
like such a [ __ ] kid again this whole
weekend man my dad showed me he's like
look at this Instagram comment from a
stranger I got and it said how I did a
good job at Carnegie Hall and he was
reading it to me and he started crying
about a [ __ ] strangers Instagram
comment you know what I mean hey Dad hey
buck up hey you're 70 buck up I'm just
[ __ ] around
I think emotional intelligence ISM is
more important than [ __ ] intelligence
intelligence you know I'm talking about
than brains like these [ __ ] smartass
numbers guys they're idiots when it
comes to everything else some of them
some of them not all of them but some of
them they just don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing in life like those kinds
of guys are always like wall street type
guys and [ __ ] that'll really they don't
they don't they don't sit down and have
like heart to hearts you know they're
like now who's got time [ __ ] turn and
burn that money trying to [ __ ] stack
[ __ ]
I'm trying to sit on [ __ ] knots hey
dude I got a [ __ ] fat wallet too but
you still got a cry sometimes there's a
quote you can have a [ __ ] fat wallet
but cry sometimes for real man yo you
could [ __ ] sit all lopsided on a knot
but you still gotta cry sometimes hey
dude you could be sitting on [ __ ]
Knott's Berry Farm but you still got a
[ __ ] crew
you still got to let some liquid leak
out of the top party of [ __ ] head
sometimes how about that too it sit on
knots but also leak it's the truth
if you're just sitting on knots and you
don't leak you ain't [ __ ] and if you
just leak and you don't sit on not so
you can still be something man you don't
have to sit on knots to not be a real
[ __ ] to be a real [ __ ] person my
uncle Vinny sits on two knots and I
think you leak sometimes but you got a
[ __ ] you got it you got a cry you got
a [ __ ] cry don't just I but I cried
on my podcast about two to three weeks
ago somebody left a comment on my things
like hey man you should have cried on
your podcast men don't men don't cry
they shouldn't cry bro what is this in
1952 who are you [ __ ] Danny Zuko bro
what are you talking about hey [ __ ]
Kenickie leak what are you talking about
men don't cry and I'm not into all this
[ __ ] cry-baby liberal [ __ ] by the way
you know how about the Red Dead
Redemption video games coming out with
some [ __ ] and they're like they worked
100 plus hours in the four weeks each
week to get this video game under you
know on a deadline and and and the
internet is like up in arms I tweeted
about it they're like oh well this is a
mismanagement you shouldn't overwork
people a hundred hours you shouldn't do
this and that people are like oh really
[ __ ] they really [ __ ] up some of
these tweets pull them up about red red
red dead redemption but it's like dude
how much fake outrage can we have dude
you don't give a [ __ ] that people are
working a hundred hour work weeks by the
way getting paid and to have a video
game come out it's like this is a
sweatshop dude and they're putting souls
on [ __ ] Saka knees or however the
hell you say that word nobody knows by
the way Ciccone Sarkin ii saucony
whatever the [ __ ] it is that's what I
would do I would have that [ __ ] who
what's the meme right there
go up yes shannon sharpe Red Dead
Redemption do campaign is 65 hours long
[Music]
that's my favorite meme of all time when
your girl asked to look through your
phone how did he say that that's the
best meme of all time I told one fired
that meme and he was like I don't like
that one and I was like you will bro
it's it's got everything it's so [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] like that faux machismo
damn dude shannon sharpe dude how about
his face that guy you couldn't create a
face better than that and he's got the
nerve to wear tortoiseshell clad dude
that guy's the man I never saw shiny
sharp not make a catch and I'm not a bit
I'm not a what was he a tight end and I
but he was a title nothing but that dude
was the [ __ ] when I was a kid I used to
watch that and sharp I'd be like man
that guy's this [ __ ] that guy would
catch every ball like dude do by the way
Shannon Sharpe I'm gonna throw it 50
yards down and you're gonna catch it
even though you're the tight end I'll
tell you what Shannon Sharpe I'm gonna
throw it not in the field but in row FF
you think you can catch it up a bit yeah
I'll [ __ ] grab hey hey we're playing
in Dallas Stadium Shannon Sharpe I'm
John Elway by the way I'm gonna throw a
[ __ ] pass all the way to the Seahawks
Stadium you think you can get shot by
the way he's just saying la la la
problem problem so the red red the red
dead redemption by the way [ __ ] Red
Dead Redemption dead red red dead red
dead ran danwon a damp Ram from
Redemption you're playing 100 Amazon the
red and redemption ax BAM chin Lampson
the lampshade on a random Redemption and
everyone's like pull-ups on the trees oh
yeah you can't work people to over 100
hours they knew what they were getting
into
they knew [ __ ] [ __ ] deadlines it was a
deadline that needed to go
stop with your [ __ ] fake outrage man
because you know what's up with that
outrage the people who are [ __ ]
working on that video game they know the
deadline is coming up and they know
they're gonna not be able to see their
family for the next few weeks and they
know they're gonna lose sleep well guess
what not a problem because that's
[ __ ] work man dude I [ __ ] worked
hard and my marriage [ __ ] dissolved
because I had to [ __ ] do open mics
and not even get paid and my ex-wife was
like what the [ __ ] this isn't what I
thought marriage was gonna be and I was
like yeah but you're not gonna [ __ ]
be saying this [ __ ] when I'm playing and
I'm throwing around the world and we're
making [ __ ] money and the Brinks
truck is [ __ ] backing up and we're
gonna be [ __ ] toting around with
diamond rings on and you're gonna have
all the dresses you want and then you're
gonna be like but right now it sucks
because we're young as [ __ ] but when
you're [ __ ] walking around like the
Queen of Sheba you're gonna be [ __ ]
[Music]
they know stop picking something stop
picking something to be upset about
that's the problem
you're picking something to be upset
about because your [ __ ] life sucks
and you're [ __ ] cubicle be happy with
what you got man because there's people
with it worse off than you now love
problem little problem
lalala problem and I see [ __ ] one
fire right and down lalala problem
because that's probably the name of the
episode dude it's it's just who gives a
[ __ ] about anything about video games
how about that plan and be happy or
don't play video games
Kudus man seeing other people are you
tweet about that I gotta tweet about
that too and here I come
at the [ __ ] anti-hero hey you
[ __ ] I put up a tweet stop
stop with all the [ __ ] there's no
Bigfoot stop stop with all the [ __ ] the
Loch Ness monster see ya would have
found him already bye
[ __ ] bones I wrote the fakeness of
people claiming outrage for Red Dead
Redemption crunching to make a deadline
it's [ __ ] so hilarious it is peak SJW
[ __ ] social justice warrior you simply
do not actually give a [ __ ] about how
hard a videogame company works to make a
deadline and you know this and this guy
writes the thing is that this has become
the standard for the industry and I
don't think it really should be I don't
like when people also put question marks
at the end of sentient things that
should be sentences most cases most
cases they don't get paid overtime
because most developers are on a salary
so a lot of the time it's people putting
themselves through hell for no bonus and
that's true so I wrote for sure however
also people on the internet don't give a
[ __ ] that's my gripe that's mm-hmm
gripe I'm just tired of [ __ ] people's
noses facing my nose man haven't faced
the same [ __ ] way um anyway that's
what's up you want to do some Twitter
questions let's do some Twitter
questions man I like Twitter because I
should shake it up and do Twitter
questions earlier sometimes because they
sometimes they leave me on a good
[ __ ] tangent like last time
dude Peabo Bryson you know hey here's
something I'm never gonna do I want to
address this actually before we even get
into Twitter questions because somebody
asked me this on Twitter I think every
[ __ ] three hours somebody writes me
hey we're gonna be at your DC show or
this in that show can you give my friend
it's her birthday can you give her a
shout-out dude imagine me stopping my
act that I've worked very hard on and
being like oh wait and being like oh
there's a birthday now did I talk about
this already on the podcast I think I
did it was on my Instagram or something
like that
I don't remember it anyway no I'm never
giving a shout-out I'm never giving a
shout-out oh you have a birthday
oh dude Europe you're the good friend
how annoying is the good friend I'm I'm
just it's not even for me my friend and
she means the world to me it's her
birthday oh really
dude let's see what it looks like when
your top lip touches your bottom lip
let's see what it looks like when it
stays there
now tell me oh you can't
thanks turn round I just uh I'll never
stop my show to give a shout-out it's
not I don't I'm not a [ __ ] DJ you
know what I mean
imagine being a DJ bro how [ __ ] awful
it must be can you play Caroline can you
play no dude
yeah yeah I'll never give a shout-out on
my [ __ ] eye you know what kind of a
comedian I don't know one comedian that
would do that to be honest what do what
do people think going a comedy show us
what the [ __ ] do you think is going on
we're getting paid the [ __ ] beaucoup
bucks to [ __ ] come in and do a show
in your city I'm not stopping it so your
friend John can feel good about his
birthday don't give a [ __ ]
we all have birthdays oh it's your
birthday dude well guess what
I'm Jay I'm a Jehovah's Witness I don't
give a [ __ ] about Ebert koshari
is your birthday and you know we don't
[ __ ] is your birthday that's me I
don't give a [ __ ]
alright Twitter questions hey Lia trib
at Lia trip hey Chris Liam what the [ __ ]
is this person say hey Chris Lea I'm a
wedding photographer and a guy tried
grinding on me during a cha-cha slide
and I turn round gunked him and uh and
another dude across the room pointed me
and yelled shrew baby that's cool two
babies United at a [ __ ] wedding
that's cool you said good gunk to a guy
that tried to grind on yeah what's up
with guys that think they could just
[ __ ] go up on a chick and grind him
just cuz they're on a dance floor boy
that's gonna be a boy I know it's out of
fashion that's gonna be illegal in about
a month and a half oh wait did you see
the girl the lady that tried to claim
that the nine-year-old sexually
assaulted her did you see that oh my god
dude it was and then I found out that
the lady was white and the kid was black
and I was just like Jesus Christ come on
Lady give white people a break there was
footage of it and then you saw the
footage and the kid literally it was his
backpack that hit her but by mistake and
she called the cops on a nine-year-old
hey even if a nine-year-old is purposely
grabbing your ass guess what you're
supposed to do
buck up you're supposed to look at that
nine-year-old and be like [ __ ] off dude
who cares you're not a survivor cuz a
nine-year-old grabbed your [ __ ] who
cares dude go to [ __ ] work [ __ ]
idiot
you're a survivor because someone
grabbed your ass you know I had a
[ __ ] I've taken a picture there was a
70 year old lady that was like a big fan
of mine she was like the funky year old
seven year old lady though she might
have been 65 something like that and she
would come see me all the time and she
was always giving me those sex eyes and
she asked for a picture of she always
asked for a picture one time she asked
for a picture and she [ __ ] took her
hand her [ __ ] 65 year old hand
grabbed my [ __ ] nuts grabbed my nuts
and I guess you know yeah sexually
assaulted me and I went hey what the
[ __ ] are you doing and then I forgot
about it then I forgot about it I
survived though you know why because in
the grand scheme of things Alex at Edie
Guerra you gotta make these bigger bro
come on when he's from [ __ ] Eagle
Edgar Roth Alex at Edgar Roth it's not a
singer isn't that the guy who sings
[Music]
who's that guy that sings that song that
Eminem ripped off and to party they put
a - Park on it I don't know anyway
whatever how do you feel about
restaurants that serve their food in a
quirky row you're a fan of mine you know
goddamn well how I feel about this first
of all but I'm gonna continue the [ __ ]
how do you feel about restaurants that
serve their food in a quirky dish like a
polished shovel or a piece of slate a
focus on making your food tasty he
writes look I agree dude oh my god
there's a [ __ ] polish we got to
retweet that from the congratulations
podcast but the dude to get a beans they
got [ __ ] chicken some sausage links
looks like veggie patties and an egg by
the way first of all how much goddamn
meat is on your plate hey man stop what
do you feed is that for seven people
the guy's eaten so much meat she's gonna
die tomorrow
hey at least you have a shovel shovel to
dig your [ __ ]
graven huh Oh [ __ ] hey and that dude
was that at Denny's cuz I just gave you
a [ __ ] piping hot Grand Slam dude
stop eating someone's night hey bro what
are you [ __ ] looking for nitrates bro
this guy loves nitrates I don't even
know what nitrates is but I know you
love nitrates bro this guy can't get
this guy's got [ __ ] lotion with
nitrates and [ __ ] you just Laura do it
someone guys like you want some [ __ ]
nitrates guys so um yeah this shovel God
if someone let me tell you something
dude if I'm at a restaurant
and somebody hands me food with any sort
of plate on it that isn't just a [ __ ]
plate first right and you know they how
about when they when you get this salmon
and they're like it's slow-cooked don't
tell me [ __ ] is slow-cooked either I
don't give a [ __ ] put it in front of me
don't brag about how long it takes for
you to make your food you suck at it
then make it quicker come on get get
[ __ ] Uncle Ben in here that guy could
do it in 60 seconds oh you slow cooked
your [ __ ] pork loin eat my ass I can
pull my pants down in two seconds and
give you a meal how about that dude and
the slams keep coming man dude you know
what if I had a Denny's I'd get a
[ __ ] revolving door that's it
I'd act like it was some place in Times
Square dude I'd act like I had a [ __ ]
newspaper and a newspaper company in the
goddamn thing cuz that's that's what's
up cuz I need a revolving door am i
Denny's cuz that's how much people are
getting the [ __ ] all-american slams
and you can get there you go there you
can create your own [ __ ] slam which is
your best what you're basically doing
anyway I literally have five I do I have
no idea what I'm talking about right now
I forgot what did he ask me oh yeah dude
have a plate me a plate that's it don't
give me a [ __ ] hubcap on a plate
you're not fun and funky focus on making
your food this guy's right make your
food good presentation comes second the
presentation is still something but if
you're a [ __ ] serving food in a
shovel or a hubcap your food sucks
okay but to see the the when they give
it to you on a wood plank that [ __ ]
drives me nuts
just put it on a ship yeah the salmon
tastes a little bit better when it's
served on cedar I don't give a [ __ ]
you're gonna give me an aneurysm now I
got a it's fallen off the thing you know
it looks like one of those old Japanese
[ __ ] shoes that women used to wear
with the wood the socks still on them uh
we got any more oh yeah dude what's up
with this this guy as David Kurtz Kurtz
David em thoughts on people who get
moustache tattoos on their fingers yeah
you know that [ __ ] where they get it
like this so they can do that and and do
the fake mustache over there what do you
what do you do what are you you know
what you are you're so so you so don't
have a personality if you do that cuz
that's in place of a personality you
think you're the fun guy cause I'm a fun
guy when you have a [ __ ] mustache and
you put it up like that like you're
trying to not sneeze by the way how
weird is it how well that works when
you're when you get are sneeze you're
like oh and you all I got to do is press
that [ __ ] that's some [ __ ] Jesus Christ
should have figured out beforehand Trump
yeah every time I do that I'm about to
sneeze I do that and I don't sneeze I
look up in the air and I go like this
hey Jesus gotcha
God those mustache fit the first guy who
did that was kind of okay cool great the
second guy who did that he couidn't guy
deserves to get butt-fucked you know are
there anymore enough that's that
that tattoos the worst tattoo maybe
besides some wooded Steve will get your
name on his ass or whatever Jesus Christ
you know come on steve-o love the guy
know him but come on anyway I guess
we're good huh
it's about one hour and six let me do
the [ __ ] wrapping up [ __ ] did I do
all the things I did all the ads blue
blue apron okay I'm gonna read it I'm
gonna put it I'm gonna do this ad how
it's said and one fire it [ __ ] it up
blue apron heck out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free at blue
apron calm slash Congrats so guys don't
forget to heck it out go online and
check it out I guess I got to say the
real way so we get so we get paid so
check it out and then download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market enter rewards code Congrats
get $5 and give five dollars - times up
thank you so much for listening and
subscribing please subscribe to the
YouTube channel
we're almost at 200,000 subscribers and
let's get there you know maybe we'll be
there by the next week I'll see you in
Miami in Jacksonville coming up West
Palm Beach Atlanta Georgia
Los Angeles San Francisco Boston
Massachusetts Fresno California
Bakersfield Austin and San Antonio for
some reason subscribe rate and review
the shows that really helps rate and
review the show I want to get in the
[ __ ] top ten here you know I think I
don't think I've got in the top ten yet
a separate when we first came out but uh
I think we've been in like twelve
recently but let's get up there do it
video episodes go up on Tuesdays or
Wednesdays and follow the leader' buy
tickets on Chris D'Elia calm new dates
for 2019 new dates for 2019 announcing
soon we got a announcing soon we got a
Chicago st. Louis like I think next week
we're doing we're gonna announce it but
we got a bunch of ones coming out
Windsor some like that's a [ __ ] place
going to Narnia
perform for some [ __ ] goats in a
closet alright guys you guys thank you
very much and you know a problem you
guys were you guys are the best man some
of you guys probably suck [ __ ] dick
though some of you guys probably suck
[ __ ] you guys thank you so much for
listening you guys are the best you know
when people say you guys are the best
thanks for listening I'd be saying that
but also with the caveat some of you
guys who listen are probably [ __ ] so
annoying and shitty and you probably
suck do it and even the people that love
that you love that love you probably
secretly think you [ __ ] suck and you
listen to the podcast but I appreciate
you too
so thanks very much guys
[Music]